[Applaudissements]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous
regardez et maintenant l'émission qui
revient toujours avec plaisir et
toujours avec vous sur l'actualité
politique de la semaine hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir sur
ce plateau aujourd'hui du beau monde du
très beau monde les amis peut-être les
meilleurs avec un nouvel élément très
prometteur aujourd'hui Hélène terziant
bonjour ravie de vous accueillir vous
êtes journaliste politique à RMC
l'illustre Christophe Bourseiller est
également sur ce plateau bonjour les
écrivains historiens je renvoie l'un de
vos derniers livres parce que vous en
écrivez beaucoup l'un de vos derniers
livres intitulés il appelait monsieur
Hitler s'est publié chez Perrin Valérie
loca bonjour communicante président de
HK stratégie et l'éléguant Alexandre
devecchio est également sur ce plateau
journaliste rédacteur en chef adjoint au
Figaro on voit votre livre apparaître à
l'écran recomposition le Nouveau Monde
populiste c'est aux éditions du Cerf
dans cette émission on essaiera
d'imaginer le général de Gaulle vendre
des rillettes sur la Place Rouge à
Moscou on verra si l'extrême droite est
de remporter la bataille des idées en
Europe si la nupesse a fait la
démonstration de son utilité un an après
sa création et puis et puis stop au
Macron bashing les amis c'est pas moi
qui le dit mais un journaliste italien
vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez
mais d'abord merci président Larcher
retour sur une nouvelle semaine de
colère sociale les manifestations du
premier 1er mai en réunit énormément de
monde partout en France plus de 2
millions de personnes selon la CGT pour
cette première journée de mobilisation
nationale depuis la promulgation de la
réforme des retraites alors est-ce que
cela peut encore durer pas pour le
sénateur LR Bruno Retailleau qui pointe
du doigt les violences dans les manifs
écoutez-le moi je pense que le processus
démocratique qu'a subi le cas parcouru
le texte sur les retraites est un vrai
parcours conforme à nos institutions
enfin le Sénat nous l'avons voté une
première fois en première lecture nous
l'avons ratifié en commission mixte
parité avec les députés
revoter ensuite donc que ça correspond à
nos institutions de la Cinquième
République et je dis l'intersyndical
quand on voit les violences je dis que
il faut savoir terminer une grève parce
qu'on voit bien que c'est en train de
dégénérer je pense qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation il y a des risques qui sont
des risques de violence d'hypervolence
et c'est très responsabilité il faut que
chacun l'assume prochaine journée de
grève et de mobilisation prévue le 6
juin c'est une annonce de l'interd
syndicale Valérie il faut savoir
terminer une grève comme le dit Bruno
Retailleau écoutez ce qui a été
extrêmement dommage le 1er mai moi je
suis allée faire un tour pour me rendre
compte c'est que la grande majorité
l'immense majorité des gens qui étaient
là étaient là pour manifester
tranquillement plutôt dans la joie la
bonne humeur et c'était la première fois
depuis 15 ans que tous les syndicats
étaient réunis pour manifester ensemble
ce jour-là qui est je vous rappelle la
fête du travail donc c'était le vrai
retour de la vraie fête du travail et ce
qui est vraiment extrêmement dommageable
et extrêmement dommage
c'est que effectivement 2000 personnes
sur les 782000 annoncé par le ministère
de l'intérieur on suffit à gâcher
complètement la fête par les violences
les exactions les violences absolument
insupportables qui ont eu lieu voilà il
y a de la violence il faut savoir
s'arrêter moi ce que je dis par rapport
à taillot c'est que il a pas tout à fait
tort parce qu'il est temps de passer à
autre chose c'est le temps de la
négociation qui commence et Laurent
Berger a dit qu'il irait discuté avec le
gouvernement et en ça je pense que c'est
constructif et positif après la
manifestation du 6 juin elle va avoir
lieu pour nos entrées simples c'est que
il y a une possibilité le 8 juin de
voter une loi contre la loi qui existe
déjà donc c'est il va un peu vite en
besogne dans la façon qu'il a s'exprimer
en fait Hélène même question voilà la
loi a été promulguée c'est ce que nous
dit Bruno Retailleau dans voilà dans les
termes de la Constitution il faut savoir
passer aussi à autre chose selon moi je
suis aussi assez d'accord avec avec vous
et avec les propos de de Bruno
retailleux à ce sujet oui je je pense
que il faut savoir arrêter une grève ils
ont réussi jusque là à avoir un front
uni les syndicats à mettre dans la rue
près de 3 millions et demi de personnes
au plus fort de la mobilisation ce sont
leurs chiffres
1,2
personnes selon les personnes c'est vrai
que depuis 20 ans ça a été plutôt très
bien mené il y a eu peu de violence au
début pour éviter que ça s'enlise pour
éviter d'avoir des grèves qui se sont
lisées ce qui se sont effrités comme en
2018 il y a eu la grève perlée contre la
réforme de la de la SNCF ça a fatigué
les usagers ça a fatigué même les
syndicats je pense que pour en sortir
par le haut Laurent Berger a la posture
la plus responsable il faut aller autour
de Matignon et ils ont intérêt à y aller
pour faire plaisir à Elisabeth si les
vins
je suis pas du tout d'accord parce que
faut arrêter la grève mais il y a plus
de grève il y a quelques jours il y a
quelques petites grèves de
fonctionnaires de temps en temps il y a
pas du tout un grand mouvement de grève
aujourd'hui par contre ce bien c'est un
mouvement social incroyablement
résilient moi ce qui me frappe c'est
l'ampleur des manifestations on
imaginait en réalité que ça allait
décroître et puis que les casseurs
allaient décrédibiliser le mouvement
mais ce qu'ils essaient de faire et que
donc petit à petit ça a laissé teindre
dans une sorte de radicalisation
de décomposition pas du tout regardez la
journée d'action qu'après c'était le
premier mai il y avait beaucoup de monde
le premier mai c'est une foule
incroyable on peut imaginer que le 6
juin il y aura encore beaucoup de monde
dans les rues il y a là un mouvement de
mécontentement populaire alors peut-être
plutôt du peuple de gauche à mon avis
mais il y a un mécontentement populaire
qui est d'une puissance tout à fait
intéressante alors la violence des Black
Blocs c'est un épiphénomène on va parler
dans cette dans un instant mais
j'aimerais voilà revenir là-dessus c'est
pour ça par contre les Black Blocs c'est
par exemple les casseroles c'est le fait
cette espèce de colère qui fait que
aujourd'hui il y a vraiment une un
ressentiment et je vois pas pourquoi ça
s'arrêterait en tout cas pour quatre
Français sur 10 je vais vous montrer
sondage elabe de la semaine pour quatre
Français sur 10 personnes ne sort
gagnant de la séquence sur la réforme
des retraites Alexandre il y a quand
même un vainqueur invaincu ou comme Cap
Français sur 10 vous dites personne ne
sort vraiment gagnant de cette séquence
quoi non surtout pas Emmanuel Macron et
surtout pas la droite je pense qu'il
manque vraiment à une dimension à Bruno
retailleux c'est quelqu'un que plutôt
cultivé ce qui est rare chez à droite il
faut vous dire la vérité plutôt
quelqu'un que j'estime mais il a pas
compris que si la droite voulait revenir
au pouvoir il fallait qu'elle prenne en
compte en partie l'électorat populaire
et là j'ai une petite nuance avec vous
Christophe bosseyez je pense qu'il y a
le peuple de gauche mais il y a le
peuple tout court 93% des actifs la
droite devrait s'adresser à cette France
qui travaille et il en est manifestement
incapable Bruno retaillod et ensuite il
dit quelque chose qui moi me choque il
dit faut que ça s'arrête parce que à
chaque fois il y a des risques de
violence et tout le monde doit prendre
ses responsabilités sous-entendus c'est
la faute des syndicats c'est pas la
faute des syndicats c'est la faute de
qui est incapable de maintenir l'ordre
donc si la droite arrive demain au
pouvoir pour dire bah faudra éviter les
grèves ou les manifestations parce qu'on
n'est pas capable de maintenir l'ordre
ça ça laisse augurer quelque chose de de
c'est pas c'est pas très crédible donc
je trouve qu'il est à côté depuis le
départ dans cette séquence Bruno
Retailleau à suivre un logiciel qui
aujourd'hui est totalement dépassé il
s'accroche au fait que la droite a
toujours été pour le fait qu'on
travaille plus longtemps mais la droite
a perdu beaucoup d'élections il faudra
parler
dans les dans les manifestations sur les
marges de cette mobilisation on a à
nouveau effectivement assisté lundi à
des violences contre les forces de
l'ordre plus de 400 policiers et
gendarmes ont été blessés et tout le
monde évidemment se renvoie un peu la
balle écouter
ne cédez pas rien jamais la lutte
continue jusqu'au retrait les premiers à
courir devant chez vous
les derniers à CD c'est vous
ah bah la mauvaise République Monsieur
le Président vous évoquez également les
nouvelles outrances du leader de la
France insoumise elle s'inscrivent dans
une remise en cause permanente de nos
institutions elles sont une nouvelle
étape pour saper la confiance de nos
concitoyens dans notre démocratie
ah bah la mauvaise République dit-il
chacun le sait bien pour Jean-Luc
mélench Mélenchon la seule bonne
République c'est lui on a l'impression
qu'on est pris entre deux stratégies
contradictoires un peu Christophe a
acquis profite ses violences et
débordements c'est compliqué là par
exemple ce que je trouve assez
extraordinaire c'est le gouvernement qui
ne cesse de faire une sorte d'amalgame
entre d'un côté les Black Blocs ce qu'on
appelle les autonomes qui se mettent en
black bloc et de l'autre la France
insoumise ces deux choses totalement
différentes jamais Mélenchon n'appelle a
casser des vitrines ou à s'en prendre à
la police totalement faux c'est vraiment
deux stratégies séparées aujourd'hui il
y a un phénomène qui est très important
et c'est peut-être ça en fait que le qui
pose problème à la police c'est le fait
que les autonomes il y en a depuis très
longtemps ça a démarré dans les années
1970 donc c'est un vieux phénomène mais
au départ les autonomes c'est la
violence spontanée des masses c'est à
dire c'est des gens qui se réunissent de
façon spontanée qui veulent détruire les
symboles du capitalisme comme on l'a
déjà dit beaucoup etc mais qui le font
dans une espèce de grands mouvements
comme ça qui n'est pas planifié alors
que dans les années 2000 là depuis 2000
le début des années 2010 on est face à
des ligues para militaire c'est
totalement différent on est face à des
gens des organisés qui ont des chefs
alors que c'était totalement
anti-hiérarchique au départ le mouvement
autonome donc là il y a une évolution
une dépolitisation du mouvement autonome
qui va de pair avec une hiérarchisation
et puis vraiment c'est de la guérilla
urbaine donc maintenant vous avez des
Chefs vous avez des commandos vous avez
des groupes qui posent des armes avant
ils ont des talkiwoki ils s'appellent
tous Camille ils mettent des musiques
pour se repérer enfin il y a tout un
système vraiment de prévention pour dire
pour pour atteindre la police plus
aisément chacun va donner un coup à la
police pour pas être comme si l'état
attaqué dire ah mais Monsieur J'ai donné
qu'un seul coup de matraque puisqu'en
fait il se un peu comme à l'accord Ida
il se il se succède tous donc vous voyez
on est dans quelque chose de totalement
nouveau et là effectivement ça pose un
problème de maintien de l'ordre il
semblerait que pour l'instant les forces
de l'ordre des beaucoup de mal à gérer
ça et du coup évidemment qu'est-ce que
ça provoque c'est l'éternel phénomène
binaire français c'est-à-dire vous avez
la droite qui dit oui les casseurs
menaces à démocratie et la gauche qui
dit oui la police nous imprime donc
entre les deux il y a peut-être une
vérité à trouver c'est à dire que il y a
sans doute des exactions policières et
il y a sans doute des casseurs qui sont
aujourd'hui des lits par un militaires
on a l'impression d'une certaine
impuissance au niveau du gouvernement si
elle aime face à ces Black Blocs alors
l'état c'est normal qu'il veuille
protéger les manifestants protéger les
commerces éviter qu'il y ait des
débordements on les a vu notamment
pendant les gilets jaunes et l'État il a
le monopole de la violence légitime il
faut aussi le rappeler maintenant il y a
certains réflexes sécuritaires qui
interroge une forme d'escalade et il y a
du côté du gouvernement du côté du
gouvernement quand la Défenseur des
droits parle de garde à vue abusive
qu'on l'a le la contrôleur des prisons
parlent également de garde à vue qui
sont instrumentalisation des gardes à
vue même instrumentalisées ça pose
question alors ils ont autorisé drone
ont été autorisés dans civil ensuite il
y a la question des arrêtés préfectoraux
anti sifflets anti-casseroles est-ce que
c'est pas aussi une forme de fébrilité
politique cette forme d'escalade de
sécurité je pense que ça interroge et il
doit aussi d'une certaine façon admettre
qu'il existe des violences policières
vous êtes d'accord il y a une escalade
sécuritaire du côté du gouvernement
effectivement hélène a rappelé tous ces
arrêtés d'interdiction des
manifestations de l'ordre des
déplacements de ministres d'Emmanuel
Macron des garde à vue répétées parfois
sans justification les interdictions
pour les manifestations c'est un sujet
qui est un petit peu différent mais je
trouve que ce je vous explique cela
c'est à dire que Christophe a très bien
décrit quelle est la nouvelle forme
compris les black-box qui ne sont pas
seulement une contestation libertaire
anarchique spontanée comme on a pu
connaître dans les années passées et qui
est devenu une guérilla urbaine rangée
et effectivement par un militaire donc
les conséquences de ça c'est que les
risques sont absolument considérables on
a vu ce policier qui est devenu une
torche vivante parce que il avait pris
une grenade où je ne sais comment ça
s'appelle et qui a été sauvé par ses
collègues donc il me semble pas
totalement anormal que la police essaye
de réagir et d'utiliser d'autres moyens
aussi que ceux qui utilisaient autrefois
pour pouvoir se protéger eux-mêmes
puisque c'est leur mission de service
public sur le sujet des drones qui fait
l'objet d'une petite
ils ont été extrêmement utiles notamment
à Lyon pour circonscrire ces Black Blocs
par rapport aux manifestants or ce sont
des outils modernes de surveillance qui
sont utilisés par les militaires depuis
très longtemps s'ils sont utilisés
uniquement en vue d'assurer la sécurité
pourquoi cela interdire on voit bien
qu'on est passé dans une autre dimension
de conflit et que donc il va falloir
opposer force contre force et pour
terminer avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
porte quand même une responsabilité
politique hallucinante de parler de
mauvaises République et de ne pas
prendre position fermement contre ces
violences puisque lui pour lui les seuls
violences sont celles de la police donc
quand même il va un peu loin dans ses
prises de police
on peut pas du tout leur reprocher de
d'avoir prôné la violence au contraire
je pense que ça les a beaucoup gênés par
contre Jean-Luc Mélenchon a quand même
des propos ambigus il appelle à la
saturrection toutes les deux minutes il
explique que la police tu sous-entendue
on peut se défendre et agresser la
police jamais il condamne fermement
qui ce qui se passe notamment ce
policier pense transformer en torche
humaine et on en vient aucune
responsabilité du côté de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon responsabilité du côté de
Mélenchon mais il y a un jeu de rôle
aussi parce que je crois que en réalité
le gouvernement a eu deux alliés
objectifs dans cette dans cette bataille
des retraites ce sont effectivement les
Black Blocs et c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon
parce que je crois que les Black Blocs
les violences malgré tout on fait que le
mouvement social est devenu moins ample
qu'il ne l'était ça a fait peur
notamment après sainte Soline qui
n'avait pas grand chose à voir avec la
réforme des retraites mais on a vu que
le les cortèges étaient moins fournis
les gens ont eu peur malgré tout le
chaos à à affaibli le mouvement social
et ensuite c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon dont
l'opposition a été tellement
caricaturale qu'elle a été
inefficace on voit d'ailleurs que c'est
Marine Le Pen qui profite de cette de
cette séquence là donc c'est un jeu de
rôle qui qui avantage le gouvernement
qui dit nous on est le parti de l'ordre
et eux c'est le parti du
du désordre donc je crois que ça les
serre mutuellement
il y a une personne en tout cas chez les
insoumis qu'il y a condamné d'une
certaine façon les violences des
médecins et également Alexis Corbière
qui est un seul député qui a dit que
c'était pas normal d'arriver à une
manifestation avec des cocktails Molotov
donc voilà et ça a été évidemment
souligné par le par le gouvernement stop
au Macron Dashing les amis ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit mais un journaliste
italien Paolo Lévy il observe avec un
peu de distance amuser ce qu'il se passe
chez nous en France et pour lui c'est
très clair Emmanuel Macron n'est pas le
problème écoutez-le du Macron va rentrer
parmi les disciplines olympiques de
Paris 2020
tellement c'est devenu répandu moi je
veux dire seulement une chose j'ai
l'impression que ici on pourrait mettre
à l'Élysée même la baie pierre et ça
serait la même chose ce n'est pas les
présidents qui sont le problème c'est un
système qui peut être trop vertical
celui de la 5e République qui crée une
déconnexion entre le pouvoir et la base
y a-t-il un Macron bashing dans les
médias une question de position très
tranchée sur ce plateau les amis nous
avons un duel ils sont presque fâchés on
va essayer de les faire dialoguer d'un
côté Valérie de l'autre Alexandre
Alexandre vous allez nous expliquer en
45 secondes pourquoi selon veut oui il y
a Macron bashing dans les médias
aujourd'hui en France
c'est peut-être un constat juste de la
part des médias ce que je constate
simplement qu'aujourd'hui que Macron est
démonétisé c'est plus facile de de
critiquer Emmanuel Macron mais c'est une
constante dans les médias français je
crois que c'est France Olivier Giesbert
qui l'a parfois pratiqué lui-même qui
disait lécher
et bien Macron affaiblit Macron ne
pouvant plus se représenter on voit bien
qu'il commence à être lâché et lâcher
c'est pas pour ça que je vais je vais
pas macroniste que je vais commencer à
le plaindre ça fait partie du travail
mais ça montre finalement la proximité
du des journalistes avec le pouvoir qui
forme parfois le mot une partie du monde
médiatique ressemble à une cour et puis
quand le monarque commence à des choix
et bien la cour effectivement n'est plus
derrière le monarque c'est à ce à quoi
on assiste aujourd'hui Valérie vous
regardez avec des éclairs dans les yeux
vous allez nous expliquer pourquoi non
selon vous il n'y a pas de Macron
bashing dans les médias il y a pas de
macrobashing parce qu'en fait les médias
ne font que refléter la réalité de la
situation et il n'y a pour ça convaincre
qu'à regarder la couverture par les
journaux internationaux qui ne sont pas
qui ne sont pas susceptibles d'être
proche ou lointain d'Emmanuel Macron ce
sont des observateurs classiques et
normaux Emmanuel Macron était un jeune
président élu qui a apporté beaucoup
d'espoir et qui a été sal dans le monde
entier au moment de son élection et
maintenant c'est vrai que dans la presse
internationale tout le monde c'est mieux
et ne comprend pas pourquoi on est
carrément quasiment en guerre civile
dans ce pays avec des manifestations à
répétition sur ce qu'ils appellent une
petite réforme en fait à avoir toutes
ces manifestations populaires et ils en
font porter à juste titre et en partie
la responsabilité sur Emmanuel Macron
donc c'est juste la réalité de la
situation qui est de la poudre de
perlimpinp merci président Emmanuel
Macron Christophe boursier était en
train de prendre des notes vous allez
nous trancher ça est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec Valérie ou plutôt avec
Alexandre juste on va rappeler le Macron
bashing qu'est-ce que c'est à dire le
bashing c'est le dénigrement
systématique est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça je suis plutôt d'accord
avec Valérie je crois que le problème
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est qu'il a
bénéficié du plus long état de grâce
qu'on ait vu dans la Cinquième
République il a il était salué
plébiscité tout le monde a vu une
nouvelle génération il y avait un monde
nouveau qui semblait se dessiner et puis
ça s'est très rapidement les ardées et
Macron multiplier il faut dire des
erreurs de management c'est un mauvais
manager d'abord il y avait ces petites
phrases à contretemps à tout moment
souvenez-vous en août 2018 le fait de
devant les au Danemark de désigner les
Français comme des Gaulois réfractaires
au changement un mois plus tard les
gilets jaunes se mettaient des casques
Gaulois en disant on est tous des
Gaulois réfractaires au changement il
n'a jamais cessé de jeter de l'huile sur
le feu par ces petites phrases ridicules
et puis par ailleurs le fait de lancer
cette réforme des retraites au pas de
charge dans une période d'inflation ou
d'angoisse des gens pour le pour leur
avenir était particulièrement malvenus
et d'un point de vue de management
encore une fois il a encore une fois
fait la preuve de son incapacité donc je
crois que Macron bashing non il y a
juste un diagnostic du fait que ce
garçon présentait très bien c'était le
genre idéal mais qu'elle arrivait le
manager n'est pas au rendez-vous en fait
finalement ce que ce que ce qui est dit
c'est que les médias suivent un peu
jugent comme la plupart des Français
l'action du chef de l'État vous pensez
que la couverture est juste est
objective je suis on est d'accord avec
tous les deux c'est la retranscription
pure de ce que nous on peut voir sur le
terrain par exemple moi j'ai eu
l'occasion pour RMC d'aller en Alsace
c'était le premier déplacement du
président après le déclenchement du 49-3
et son allocution télévisée c'est pas
les médias qui sortent les casseroles
c'est pas les médias qui vont conspuer
le président quand il fait un bain de
foule il s'est fait littéralement
siffler et interpeller le président de
la République ce qu'on peut ajouter
aussi c'est que il est il y a une colère
contre le président de la part des
Français il y a aussi une colère de la
part de certains dans la majorité quand
on discute hors micro avec certains dans
les rangs de la majorité quelqu'un m'a
déjà dit un député il est c'est un
monarque il a dit comme il fait du
bonapartisme et il méprise le Parlement
et là ils n'ont pas une des divergences
de fonds avec lui mais de forme donc
c'est vraiment sa personnalité qui pose
problème aujourd'hui je pense pour les
Français c'est pas se représenter ça
joue aussi sur notre jugement mais tout
ce diagnostic aurait pu être fait depuis
longtemps la fracture entre les élites
et le peuple et particulièrement entre
Emmanuel Macron et le on voit bien qu'il
y a une partie des français auquel il
n'a jamais su parler et d'être pas dire
enfin les gilets jaunes c'est payé alors
bon Christophe bourseguy parlait des
Gaulois réfractaires c'était au début de
son mandat on pourra rajouter ceux qui
ne sont rien donc tout ça est pas
nouveau mais on voit bien quand il est
affaibli les langues se délient plus
plus facilement dans le monde dans le
monde médiatique le fait qu'ils ne
puisse pas se représenter selon vous ça
joue aussi notamment pour sa majorité en
réalité ce que ce que nous expliquait
madame c'est que sa majorité c'est sauf
qu'il peut le chef est démonétisé donc
il faut il faut se démarquer du chef
mais jusqu'ici il l'avait suivi il y
avait un peu aussi de bashing contre
François Hollande contre Nicolas Sarkozy
on assistait un peu à la même chose
Valérie selon vous non mais c'est vrai
que ce que dit le journaliste italien
c'est à dire qu'en France c'est
difficile de ne pas être conspuée après
avoir été élu les médias aiment jeter ce
qu'ils ont ce qu'ils ont adoré mais
après ça n'exonère pas de l'échec de
cette réforme en termes d'opinion
dire l'opinion les médias les dans
l'opinion cette réforme ne passe pas je
veux dire c'est pas les médias les
médias c'est une caisse de résonance ce
sont les Français qui ne comprennent pas
ce qui est en train de se passer ça a
été mal expliqué sincèrement depuis le
début vous m'avez présentez comme
communicante je suis aussi journaliste
enfin peu importe mais depuis le début
non mais depuis le début ils n'ont pas
su expliquer et c'est très étonnant
parce que Emmanuel Macron est quelqu'un
qui a eu une intelligence quand même
assez il a gagné cette élection et deux
fois etc il a une vraie intelligence
politique et qu'il n'est pas été capable
lui-même de raconter l'histoire de cette
réforme des retraites qui n'est pas une
très grande réforme il faut le redire
par rapport à tous les pays d'Europe
c'est absolument incompréhensible qu'il
n'est pas pris la peine de d'expliquer
aux gens de préparer le terrain de
raconter l'histoire avant et qu'il ait
débarqué comme ça ou alors il fallait le
faire en septembre en un seul coup comme
j'avais dit ici
et ça réduirait moins longtemps et on ne
serait pas au mois de mai en train de
parler encore de cette
un an les parties de gauche concluaient
une alliance pour les élections
législatives cette semaine c'était donc
un peu l'heure du bilan des discussions
ont été organisées pour envisager
l'avenir de la nupestres est-ce que par
exemple la gauche présentera une seule
et unique lisse au élections européennes
de l'année prochaine c'est pas vraiment
gagné partira pas ensemble aux
européennes mais on a après du temps
pour travailler d'ici 2027 si on doit
travailler ensemble sous forme de
coalition pour 2027 c'est pas parce
qu'on est d'accord surtout c'est parce
qu'on a pris acte des règles de la 5ème
République qui nous invite à travailler
en coalition pour gagner et donc il y a
objectivement pas de raison de faire une
coalition à tout prix voilà nous on a
des électeurs qui votent vert à chaque
élection quand ils peuvent qui veulent
voter vers aux européennes et aussi
parce que nous voulons une Europe forte
et fédérale on est peut-être pas les
seuls au monde à le vouloir tant mieux
ce qui nous sépare est devenu moins
important nous on parle de désobéissance
sur un certain nombre de choses qui
seront nécessaires eux par le dérogation
enfin c'est pas franchement que toi
qu'on en est à ce niveau là non dans un
couple et encore plus dans un couple à 5
quand même à 5 partenaires si jamais il
y a une infidélité ça doit pas conduire
au divorce voilà un couple A5 Hélène
c'est pas forcément la meilleure manière
la meilleure manière de fêter c'est un
an il parle de coupleton qu'ils ont
essayé les thérapies les thérapies là
cette semaine il y a eu deux réunions
réunions des chefs à plumes des
différents partis mardi soir je crois
une autre avec tous les députés de
l'inter-groupe ils se sont mis sur la
tête il y a eu des expressions qui sont
sorties dans la presse Fabien Roussel
qui parle de la nuit parce que camisole
marine tournelée qui refuse mais en
diffuse de faire une liste aux
Européennes je pense que il y a un nom
c'était une idée de génie de la part de
LFI et dans le Mélenchon de dire Élysée
moi Premier ministre et faisons cette
inter-groupe ils ont gagné énormément de
place et de sièges à l'Assemblée
maintenant je pense qu'il faut s'arrêter
les divergences de fond ce voile et
limite de forme également et on voit
qu'aux européennes aux prochaines
échéances électorales ça va coincer
faisons le bilan si vous voulez bien ça
fait un an est-ce qu'on peut parler de
bilan globalement positif pour
paraphraser l'autre c'est dire qu'en
fait il y a surtout un malentendu c'est
à dire que en réalité qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé lors des élections
présidentielles Mélenchon a fait un
score remarquable les autres ont fait
des scores très faibles donc Mélenchon
c'est poser en rassembleur de la gauche
en nouveau rebâtisseurs de la gauche et
puis tout le monde est venu mendier une
place dans son union et tout le monde
s'est rapproché de lui aujourd'hui les
choses ont beaucoup évolué aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que les vers pensent qu'ils
ont une carte à jouer dans le contexte
environnemental actuel et qu'au fond il
peut être que ça leur a pas tellement
plu le fait que beaucoup de jeunes
électeurs votent Mélenchon lors de
l'élection présidentielle en pensant que
c'était lui le meilleur écolo donc ils
ont peut-être envie aussi d'exister à
côté de ça le Parti communiste lui sont
carrément déjà en dehors de la nupette
en plus je trouve que Mélenchon est
assez injuste vis-à-vis de Fabien
Roussel parce que il est fâché avec lui
en disant si j'ai perdu c'est parce que
Fabien Houssen c'est pas la
présidentielle enfin il aurait pu dire
la même chose de Yannick Jadot ou dan
Hidalgo parce que les autres de la
nupesse sont tous présentés des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
donc évidemment c'est un raisonnement
qui ne tient pas la route ce qui fait
qu'à l'arrivée aujourd'hui vous avez une
sorte d'inter-groupe technique c'est un
peu liant
d'inter-groupe technique qui s'appelle
laupèpes et qui durera le temps que ça
durera si je peux permettre d'obtenir
des questions différemment dans quel
état serait la gauche aujourd'hui s'il y
avait pas la nups Alexandre elle serait
éclatée tous ces parties là en réalité
aurait beaucoup moins d'élus les s'il y
a eu la nuit Pesse c'est pour sauver
leur siège c'est pas pour des raisons
idéologiques mais peut-être qu'ils
auraient pas le déshonneur puisque il y
a des positions quand même très
différentes si la droite pendant des
années on nous a expliqué que la droite
pouvait pas s'allier au rassemblement
national parce que c'était honteux il y
avait un cordon sanitaire bon Jean-Luc
Mélenchon me paraît au moins aussi
extrémiste que Marine Le Pen donc ceux
qui donnaient des leçons on voit bien
que c'est à géométrie variable donc ils
auraient éviter le déshonore et
peut-être qu'il serait pu se concentrer
sur la
la construction d'un véritable projet
idéologique là ce sera pas le cas mais
je crois qu'ils ont aussi un problème de
de chef charismatique un problème
d'idées parce que c'est pas très bien
qu'elles sont leurs idées et que
finalement cette nups même si elle a
aucune cohérence idéologique va tenir
moi je pense encore longtemps autour du
plus petit des nominateur commun qui
malgré son côté clivant et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon parce que c'est un chef qui a
charisme
a profité à qui à la France insoumise
les autres partis politiques que ce soit
le parti communiste les écolos ou le
Parti socialiste aurait eu exactement le
même nombre de députés à l'Assemblée
nationale s'ils avaient socialistes ont
pu sauver quelques siège aussi pendant
la lessive en tout cas ce qui est mis en
avant au sein des lustre
qui devaient avoir de toute façon donc
c'est la France insoumise en raison du
score à la présidentielle qui a
bénéficié d'un effet accélérateur et qui
leur a permis d'avoir énormément de
députés donc moi je complètement en faux
sur cette stratégie que je trouve
absolument dramatique pourquoi je la
trouve dammatiques parce que la France
insoumise c'est l'extrême voilà on peut
discuter des avantages des extrêmes des
uns et des autres mais je pense que dans
ce pays c'était ce sont des parties
responsables qui doivent arriver pour
prendre le pouvoir je veux dire la
gauche dans le passé a pris le pouvoir
sous François Mitterrand dans des
parties de responsabilité pas dans des
parties de révolution radicale quand
même sous Mitterrand aussi non pas très
radicale du tout c'est le PS qui était
en tête sous Mitterrand avec le
capitalisme etc on se rappelle des
mitterrands ça n'a rien
à voir ce qu'on expériment aujourd'hui
donc je pense que pour reprendre la main
pour construire un programme et pour
pouvoir se projeter sur 2027 il est
urgent que la nupesse explose et que la
France aux élections européennes et que
la France insoumise redeviennent ce
qu'elle était c'est comme ça ce sondage
ouais ce sont ce sondage de ifopes pour
le JDD qui nous dit que 76% des
sympathisants de gauche sont favorables
parce que les parties de la nups
présentent précisément une liste unique
pour les européennes de 2024 qui a un
décalage aujourd'hui entre le peuple de
gauche ou les sympathisants de gauche et
les responsables politiques Christophe
ça a toujours été le cas aujourd'hui
vous avez par exemple en France il y a
une gauche il y a une droite qui existe
en réalité la France est restée un pays
très binaire et puis vous avez des
leaders politiques qui disent oui c'est
un monde nouveau il faut dépasser les
clivages se positionner différemment
mais vous avez une gauche par exemple
sociologique qu'on voit de qu'on a vu
descendre dans la rue ces dernières
années enfin notamment avec la réforme
des retraites en partie et ça indéniable
et moi ce que je trouve intéressant
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui se passe autour
de Bernard Cazeneuve Carole delgard des
gens comme ça qui sont en train de
constituer une gauche anti-mélant
ça existe encore il y a pas que Léon
Trotsky dans la gauche il y a aussi Jean
Jaurès il y a aussi Guy Mollet il y a
aussi des devoirs de François Mitterrand
il y a des gens toute sorte donc
peut-être que pas raisonnable cette
cette ligne là mérite d'être entendu
Alexandre vous avez quelque chose à dire
là je pense qu'il y a quand même nos
compositions profond on y reste une
gauche sociologique mais on voit bien
que toute rassemblé avec ses différents
ça fait 22% ou 23% donc on est plus
c'est plus le grand clivage n'est plus
le clivage droite-gauche il subsiste
mais il est moins important qu'un
clivage entre ceux qui sont pro
mondialisation je le fais de manière
rapide et ceux qui sont pour des
protections face à la mondialisation que
ce soit sur les questions identitaires
ou sur les les questions les questions
sociales donc
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
et je crois que le problème d'associal
démocratie c'est que elle est plus assez
socialiste justement en réalité Bernard
Cazeneuve il y a une différence de style
avec Emmanuel Macron mais ils sont tout
aussi européens ils ont été dans le même
gouvernement qui était le gouvernement
François Hollande dont Emmanuel Macron a
été conseillé puis ministre des Finances
donc on voit pas tellement le projet
alternatif de la sociale démocratie dans
une époque où il y a Valérie à
redistribué justement ce que Alexandre
omet de dire c'est que dans le
macronisme il y a une large part de
socialiste en fait et donc
socialiste là quand il y aura plus le
macronisme ce qui est inéluctable
puisqu'il n'a pas construit de vrais
partis politiques et qu'il ne se
présentera pas en 2027 naturellement ils
vont retourner au bercail c'est à dire
ils vont retourner à une gauche de
responsabilité mais qui sera la gauche
en fait et là ils se sont perdus
provisoirement dans cette événement
incroyable qui a été l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron mais moi je pense que
il n'est pas du tout impossible qui
autour du clivage droite gauche qu'il
revienne derrière il y a un journal qui
vient de se lancer mener par Laurent
geffrin qui essaye de porter ses valeurs
là et qui et qui raconte cette histoire
là et donc il n'est pas du tout écrit
que parce que l'extrémisme envoie bien
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui vous avez
deux extrêmes vous avez le rassemblement
national et LFI et ne pèse disons ils
arrêtent pas de voter voter d'émotions
de censure des propositions de loi etc
mais ils s'entendent pas donc il y a pas
d'alternative il y a pas d'alternance
c'est pas forcément très extrême dans la
française soumise c'est la gauche de la
gauche tout comme le RN c'est la droite
de la droite enfin il y a évidemment une
une
saute un peu en effet miroir l'un par
rapport à l'autre tout à fait non
il y a une question Mélenchon c'est la
question centrale qui travaille
tous les partis qui sont au sein de la
nuitpesse aujourd'hui contrairement à ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure vous
dites c'était le dénominateur commun oui
ça l'a été
maintenant il a il a parlé je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est celui qui qui
crispe la nuit Pesse et qui empêche la
nuit Pesse de passer le cap des un an il
y a d'autres personnalités politiques je
pense au sein de la nupette ce qui ont
des ambitions d'ailleurs je pense
pas trop caché je pense à François
Ruffin par exemple qui aujourd'hui
s'installe tranquillement pose déjà à
Londres pour se montrer un peu plus
républicain qui parle un peu plus aux
autres partis et je pense que c'est des
personnalités qui qui peuvent davantage
séduire
la personnalité de Jean-Luc Le Mélenchon
et clivante mais il a fait ses preuves à
chaque fois en campagne électorale il
faut que j'ai plutôt de la sympathie
pour François Ruffin parce que je pense
qu'il est un quart d'une ligne
intéressante pour l'instant est-ce qu'il
est capable de rassembler son propre
camp la France insoumise c'est pas sûr
et toute la gauche c'est pas sûr non
plus donc finalement Jean-Luc Mélenchon
malgré sa personnalité clivante comme
c'est un animal politique
incroyable il faut bien le reconnaître
ça continue à dominer son propre corps
et moi je pense qu'il a tout faire pour
être candidat à la prochaine fois c'est
la limite aujourd'hui Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aussi de cette gauche qui vise 2027
Christophe c'est une des limites
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait choisi son
dauphin en la personne d'Adrien catenin
Adrien Catena sa faute oui c'est raté
donc à partir de là Mélenchon s'est
retrouvé dans une situation difficile il
est très opposé en fait on sent qu'il y
a une certaine acrimonie vis-à-vis de
François Ruffin donc effectivement il
semblerait qu'aujourd'hui la fenêtre de
tir pour lui s'il veut continuer à
exister politiquement c'est ce
représenter directement en 2027 ce qu'il
fera peut-être ou pas on le verra on a
un peu c'est un peu trop tôt pour le
dire mais c'est sûr que le dauphin a
chuté ça c'est l'extrême droite est-elle
en train de remporter la bataille des
idées en Europe dans le nord du
continent en tout cas le populisme gagne
du terrain dernier exemple en date la
Finlande qui est en pleine négociation
sur son futur gouvernement le centre
droit a annoncé être prêt à gouverner
avec l'extrême droite qui d'ailleurs
n'en est pas une écoutez
nous n'avons pas de partie d'extrême
droite en Finlande nous avons les Vrais
Finlandais mais ne sont pas d'extrême
droite c'est pourquoi je suis prêt à
négocier avec eux
bien sûr qu'il y a des problèmes mais
nous avons bien coopéré c'est un parti
comme les autres et je suis prêt à
négocier
l'extrême droite a-t-elle gagné la
bataille des idées en Europe une
question deux positions extrêmement
tranchées sur ce plateau d'un côté
Alexandre et de l'autre Christophe
Christophe vous allez nous dire en 45
secondes c'est un duel pourquoi selon
vous non l'extrême droite n'a pas gagné
la bataille des idées alors l'extrême
droite est-ce qu'on peut vraiment parler
d'extrême droite moi je parle à plutôt
de populisme plus précis les partis
populistes n'ont pas gagné la bataille
des idées tout simplement parce que les
populistes ne s'adressent pas aux idées
mais à l'affect les populistes
s'adressent au cerveau reptilien les
populistes s'adressent veulent rassurer
les gens qui votent pour les populistes
sont des gens qui ont peur qui ont peur
que les immigrés les envahissent qui ont
peur que les frontières s'ouvrent qui
ont peur d'un monde nouveau qu'il est
terrifie qui aimerait bien revenir au
franc qui aimerait bien revenir à un
monde ancien d'une certaine façon et
donc on n'est pas du tout dans le
domaine des idées on est vraiment dans
le domaine de l'arrêt de la secte on est
dans le domaine de l'instinct on est
dans le domaine des passions et donc les
populistes il y a une bataille qui le
gagneront toujours c'est la bataille des
passions mais c'est pas avec des
passions qu'on gouverne bravo vous avez
respecté votre temps sacré duel
Alexandre 45 secondes vous allez le dire
pourquoi vous êtes pas d'accord avec
Christophe
des pays qui sont actuellement dirigés
par des coalitions composés de l'extrême
droite il y a l'Italie évidemment la
Suède la Pologne la Hongrie la Lettonie
ou encore la Slovaquie Valérie vous
constatez évidemment cette cette poussée
populiste selon vous l'extrême droite
c'est toujours la même question a-t-elle
gagné la bataille des idées ou a-t-elle
en train de la gagner non pour moi
l'extrême droite n'a pas gagné la
bataille des idées parce que déjà les
pays que vous venez de citer sont loin
d'être le cœur de l'Europe les grands
pays européens en dehors de l'Italie non
pas du tout basculer vers l'extrême
droite donc ça c'est un constat
totalement objectif deuxièmement moi je
suis assez d'accord sur le fait qu'on ne
construit pas l'avenir avec le passé
c'est à dire que à quoi ça rime de
vouloir refermer des choses ça n'a pas
de sens ça existe c'est comme si on
disait qu'Internet ne doit pas exister
que la mère ne monte pas sur la plage à
marée haute que voilà il faut affronter
l'avenir et la modernité des choses et
voir comment elles peuvent se passer
après que le libéralisme qui a été et
qui est le cœur quand même de la
doctrine initiale d'Emmanuel Macron ai
besoin de protection ce qu'il est en
train de découvrir oui bien sûr qu'il a
besoin de protection donc il faut
protéger les gens mais c'est pas du
populisme c'est plus effectivement de la
social-démocratie de responsabilité de
gauche etc il faut que les gens il faut
pas laisser les gens au bord du chemin
c'est ça la clé pour moi de ce qui se
passe dans ce pays depuis 6 ans c'est
qu'on a laissé trop de gens au bord du
chemin je parle de la France
on les a laissés au bord du chemin les
gens qui qui veulent pas de la retraite
on les a laissés au bord du chemin tous
ces gens-là on n'a pas réussi à les
embarquer dans cette mondialisation
folle ou les meilleurs sentir le
ruissellement n'a pas eu lieu c'est un
des slogans du premier mai il n'a pas eu
lieu on n'a pas réussi à répandre et
pour moi c'est cette solidarité c'est
une solidarité sociale socialiste
qui aurait du sens mais qui n'est pas on
va juste revenir peut-être juste sur sur
ce sujet camarades il y a un débat sur
ce plateau vous parlez de populisme mais
pas d'extrême droite Alexandre n'aime
pas non plus qu'on en place ce terme
est-ce que ça veut pas dire finalement
que l'extrême droite est devenu
mainstream et c'est un peu devenu une
sorte de droite c'est ce que tout
simplement pas confondre les termes
c'est tout bah c'est une question de
rigueur scientifique pour moi l'extrême
droite c'est le fascisme ce sont des
gens qui veulent un changement radical
de société et qui veulent y parvenir par
la violence pour établir un ordre
nouveau basé sur des inégalités
naturelles c'est ce qui se passe en
Grèce par exemple avec aube dorée mais
par contre dans le cas des partis
populistes ils ne veulent pas établir
une société fasciste ils ne veulent pas
le faire par un coup d'État donc pour
moi ça relève du populisme et je
distingue les deux même si vous voyez
bien qu'en France pardon vous voyez bien
qu'en France c'est un mouvement
d'extrême droite ordre nouveau qui a eu
l'idée en 1972 de créer le Front
national on va puisque vous parlez de la
France on va revenir en France avec ses
propos de Gérald Darmanin qui ont
beaucoup fait parler cette semaine
j'irai de Damana qui s'en prend à
Georgia Mélanie chef du gouvernement
italien depuis 6 mois et représentant
d'un parti post fasciste écoutez Gérald
Darmanin
ce qui se passe à Menton oui il y a un
afflux de personnes migrantes et
notamment de mineur parce que Madame
Meloni d'ailleurs le gouvernement
italienne
de Madame Le Pen est incapable de régler
des problèmes migratoires sur lequel
était élu la vérité c'est qu'il y a en
Tunisie notamment si en Libye mais
surtout en Tunisie une situation
politique qui fait que beaucoup de
d'enfants notamment remontent par
l'Italie et qui t'a dit est incapable
vous savez bien la une des journaux on
fait les titres de gérer cette pression
migratoire
ça veut dire que Madame mennoni c'est
comme Madame Le Pen c'est-à-dire que
elle se fait élire sur vous allez voir
ce que vous allez voir et puisqu'on voit
c'est que ça s'arrête pas Hélène comment
vous interprétez ces propos de Gérald
Darmanin le camp présidentiel est dans
une phase d'offensive aussi à l'égard du
rassemblement national il faut avoir ça
en tête c'est à dire qu'ils ont pris
conscience qu'ils n'ont pas assez
attaqué le RN sur le fond et la forme
pendant les retraites parce qu'ils
étaient très silencieux donc ça fait
partie de cette stratégie là il compare
Meloni et Marine Le Pen
forcément l'Italie inspire Marine Le Pen
et le rassemblement national il faut
faire en tout cas un tout petit peu
attention Marine Le Pen c'est pas je
crois qu'elle l'a dit dans un journal
italien d'ailleurs c'est pas la sœur de
George Amélie elles sont d'accord sur
certaines idées mais la ligne 13
identitaire de George mélodie ne
convient pas totalement à Marine Le Pen
c'est ce qu'elle dit en tout cas elle
trouve qu'il est plus proche dans
Zemmour et puis sur la question
ukrainienne et sur le conflit
ukra Ukraine Russie elles sont pas tout
à fait elles sont pas tout à fait
d'accord
que genre jamais
elle est plus neutre à l'égard de russe
de la Russie tandis que genre des
fondamentale compétition de concurrents
sur ce thème migratoire Alexandre
finalement géralden Armana nous dit un
peu ce qu'il avait dit ce qu'il avait
dit à Marine Le Pen vous êtes molle sur
ce sujet oui mais le problème on peut
faire le bilan de Georgia améloni il
faudra le faire bon allez déjà c'est la
semaine dernière
elle est assez populaire mais
effectivement il y a une crise
migratoire en Italie l'Europe à sa part
de responsabilité là-dedans mais Gérald
Darmanin est très mal placé c'est ça le
problème pour donner des leçons à
Georgia la mélodie c'est à dire que tout
ce qu'il dit contre Marine Le Pen ou
contre Georgia Meloni lui revient en
boomerang c'est quand même l'homme qui a
mis 6 mois à expulser le l'imam it USM
c'est l'homme ou l'océan Viking est
arrivé
les les les clandestins sont partis dans
dans la nature il a un bilan tellement
si l'homme du Stade de France il y a un
bilan tellement mauvais lui-même en
matière d'immigration que c'est
difficile de donner la leçon aux autres
donc moi je comprends pas tellement ce
qu'il fait et puis en plus c'est une
erreur diplomatique au moment où le
ministre des Affaires étrangères
italiens arrivaient parce que genre
jamais Léonie on a le droit de la
critiquer de ne pas l'aimer mais
normalement on respecte quand on est au
pouvoir la souveraineté de ses voisins
et de ses alliés l'Italie est un pays
allié et là il y a une faute
diplomatique parce que j'aurais jamais
là unique Comblain ou non elle
représente les Italiens vous dites vous
savez pas ce que ce que fait Charles
Darmanin il court un peu après les idées
l'extrême droite ou de la droite
je m'inscris en faux sur le fait que
essayer de d'organiser l'immigration
soit une idée d'extrême droite je pense
que maintenant c'est une idée qui qui
non mais c'est à gauche a pris ce thème
d'ailleurs exactement ce n'est pas pour
moi ce n'est pas une idée d'extrême
droite et je regrette que la loi sur
l'immigration qui a été prévue comme
étant la prochaine loi après la loi sur
les retraites a été repoussée à
l'automne voire au calendes parce que on
ne peut pas nier ce problème si on se
cachant les yeux sur les difficultés
d'un pays que on arrive justement aux
populismes extrêmes droites et donc je
pense qu'il y a un consensus maintenant
dans ce pays et dans tous les pays
d'Europe pour affronter le sujet et
c'est vrai c'est oui mais c'est pas
c'est pas une porosité des idées
d'extrême droite c'est la situation avec
l'immigration en Europe qui conduit les
pays européens à prendre le
responsabilité et à essayer de gérer ce
sujet pour justement éviter le populisme
affectif dont parlait Christophe tout à
l'heure et qui n'apportera que des
mauvaises solutions
votre personnel politique est-il sous
influence et notamment sous influence
russe c'est l'objet d'une commission
d'enquête mise en place à l'Assemblée
nationale à l'initiative du
rassemblement national cette semaine
c'était au tour de François Fillon
d'être auditionné jusqu'au déclenchement
de la guerre en Ukraine l'ancien Premier
ministre assiéger dans les conseils
d'administration de deux entreprises
russes dont une liée au régime de
Vladimir Poutine bon ok et alors
écoutez-le à partir du moment où j'ai
quitté la vie publique je veux le
rappeler je veux dire je suis une
personne privée et je mène ma carrière
professionnelle comme je l'entends si
j'ai envie de vendre des rillettes sur
la place sur la Place Rouge je vendrai
des rillettes sur la Place Rouge je le
dis parce que
cette idée que parce que j'ai été
premier ministre je n'ai plus le droit
de d'avoir quelques activités
professionnelle que ce soit ce qui est
pas du tout ce que vous avez dit mais
c'est ce que pense un certain nombre
d'observateurs
ça n'est pas pour moi pour moi pour moi
acceptable un ancien Premier ministre
peut-il vendre des rillettes sur la se
passe rouge en fait peut-il travailler
où il veut quand il veut avec qui il
veut deux invités sur ce plateau ne sont
pas d'accord c'est à nouveau un duel
décidément cette émission les amis et
pleine de duels Christophe d'un côté de
l'autre Valérie Christophe vous allez me
dire pourquoi selon vous oui en 45
secondes oui bah François Fillon il fait
un peu ce qu'il veut oui François Fillon
a le droit de faire ce qu'il veut il
n'est plus effectivement Premier
ministre donc il a le droit de vendre
des rillettes sur la Place Rouge parce
que cette sonde qualité bien sûr en
revanche évidemment ça pose quelques
questions sur le passé politique de
François Fillon c'est à dire que vu ses
accointenses avec les sociétés russes on
se demande ce qui serait passé s'il
avait été élu président de la République
à l'époque donc c'est vrai que ça pose
quelques questions mais sinon je pense
qu'effectivement à partir du moment où
on est plus Premier ministre et on en
plus abandonné toute carrière politique
on est libre de faire ce qu'on veut dans
les limites de la loi c'est votre
dernier mot il vous reste 10 secondes si
vous avez renoncer à ses activités
lorsque la guerre d'Ukraine a éclaté
donc ce n'est pas très très son pays
donc
très bien Valérie 45 secondes attendez
que le chronopart et vous allez me dire
François a été premier ministre il a été
candidat à l'élection présidentielle il
aurait même pu être élu s'il n'y avait
pas eu des circonstances particulières
qu'il en ont empêché et en tant que tel
il représente la France donc avoir un
ancien Premier ministre candidat à la
présidente de la République aussi proche
de l'établissement russe et de Vladimir
Poutine c'était déjà très compliqué
avant et ça le serait encore plus depuis
la guerre en Ukraine même si là
évidemment démissionné depuis il ne peut
pas faire ce qu'il veut il peut faire
tout ce qu'il veut de sa vie privée bien
évidemment et avoir toutes les activités
mais c'est quelqu'un d'assez c'est
intéressant intelligent et avec de
grandes qualités pour trouver d'autres
activités que des activités en lien
direct avec la Russie et en particulier
aujourd'hui Hélène vous imaginez le
général de Gaulle travaille pour les
Russes
mais je pense que que François Fillon ne
devrait pas dire ce qu'il a dit devant
la commission et ne devrait pas selon
moi faire ce qu'il a fait ça reste un
homme d'État un ancien Premier ministre
qui vous l'avez dit aurait pu être
président de la République
en disant qu'il a quitté la vie publique
en 2017 et qu'il fait ce qu'il veut oui
légalement il fait ce qu'il veut après
je pense qu'il y a une question éthique
qui se pose ce qui est légal n'est pas
forcément morale et je souhaitable
Alexandre sur ce point je suis d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit moi je pense qu'il
y a le problème c'est que ce soit la
Russie si c'était un autre pays est-ce
qu'on ferait autant
il y a un problème en France de conflit
d'intérêt avec les anciens Premier
ministre d'autres dont je ne citerai pas
le nom ont des liens d'intérêt avec la
Chine je suis pas sûr que ce soit
tellement neutre la Chine
on devine qui sait mais il y en aurait
d'autres la Chine a tout intérêt à
affaiblir la souveraineté française donc
un ancien Premier ministre qui est censé
défendre la nation ça souverain se vend
que ce que ces anciens premiers livres
sous ses anciens ministres se vendent à
des puissances étrangères oui ça pose un
problème et c'est pas un problème
seulement français on pourrait citer le
cas de Monsieur Guérard Schroder on a vu
d'ailleurs que la politique énergétique
de l'Allemagne était-elle totalement
inféodée à la Russie parce que Monsieur
garachreder travaillait effectivement
pour les Russes et quand ils sont
anciens Premier ministre ou anciens
dirigeants il conserve des liens avec
l'administration des réseaux et donc ça
pose oui un vrai problème de
souveraineté ça dit beaucoup sur des
élites qui sont totalement dévoyés qui
n'ont plus le qui ne sont plus patriotes
aujourd'hui je pense que François Fillon
d'accord il fait ce qu'il veut vendre
des rillettes sur la Place Rouge ou
ailleurs mais qu'il ne disent pas que
c'est un patriote français ce n'est pas
vrai juste pour qu'on comprenne quel est
l'intérêt pour la Russie de recruter
comme ça des anciens premiers ministres
des responsables politiques c'est quoi
c'est le carnet d'adresses Russie qui a
recruté Fillon je crois que c'est des
sociétés probablement Fillon avait des
accointances avec un certain nombre de
d'oligarques russes
qui lui ont permis de retrouver du
travail après son éviction du monde
politique ce qui est évidemment
inquiétant c'est de voir qu'il avait des
accointances avec des oligarques russes
et non pas des oligarques je sais pas
quoi Suisse ou italien ou allemand enfin
voilà tout est là peut-être mais à
partir de là moi personnellement ça ne
me gêne en rien qu'il est pas une forme
d'ingérence parce que faut rappeler que
cette commission d'enquête a été mise en
place à l'Assemblée nationale par le
rassemblement national pour enquêter de
lien avec la Russie pour enquêter sur
ces formes d'ingérence en France est-ce
que vous y voyez une forme d'ingérence
vous Valérie que François Fillon
travaille pour des recrutement c'est
qu'il y a il y a depuis de très longues
années et bien avant ces histoires de
guerre en Ukraine et d'autres pays le
font tout à fait il y a un lobbying fort
pour avoir des réseaux d'amitié entre la
France et la Russie comme comme avec
d'autres pays voilà donc sur le papier
ce n'est pas un problème d'avoir des
réseaux d'amitié entre la France et
d'autres pays simplement il faut juste
savoir avec quel objectif pour faire
quoi et être capable de mettre ça dans
un contexte international et
géopolitique qui soit responsable on ne
peut pas s'allier tout le temps avec
n'importe qui voilà il y a des pays avec
qui ça peut être possible il y en a
d'autres avec qui c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué
parfois des intérêts politiques et que
ce soit parfois des intérêts qui sont
contraires aux intérêts français donc je
pense que c'est un peu naïve de parler
de réseau d'amitié mais effectivement ça
touche pas que la Russie ça pourrait
être
sa défense François Fillon nous dit
voilà dans sa défense il dit vous êtes
un peu maniché il y aurait le bien d'à
côté et le mal de l'autre et pourquoi
pas on parle des pays on parle pas
de manière générale les hommes
politiques de haut niveau ou même de de
faible niveau devrait
éviter de travailler pour des puissances
étrangères qui ont d'autres intérêts que
la puissance française ou même des
grands groupes internationaux qui
pourraient en concurrence avec des
entreprises françaises donc il faudrait
quoi légiférer peut-être sur les anciens
premiers ministres d'anciens présidents
qui faudrait interdire certaines
pratiques tout à fait absurde je suis
pas du tout d'accord je pense que quand
tant qu'on exerce une profession des
soumises aux règles liées à cette
profession quand on ne l'exerce plus
c'est comme quand on a fait de la prison
quand on sort de prison on fait ce qu'on
veut on peut dire c'est même quand on a
exercé les plus grandes responsabilités
il y a une autorité de transparence
cette activité là mais je je la respecte
de transparence de la vie politique
française qui existe aujourd'hui et qui
examine au moment où quelqu'un par
exemple quand Jean Castex a été nommé
président de la RATP si je me trompe pas
et il a dû répondre devant cette
autorité pour vérifier que le le travail
n'a pas de lien avec les anciennes
fonctions donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui existe déjà et qui fonctionne ça
pose aussi
la puissance étrangère mais moi je ne
comprends pas le pantouflage le fait par
exemple que des hauts fonctionnaires
travaillent tantôt pour l'État tantôt
pour des grandes entreprises reviennent
travailler pour l'État ça pose un
problème de conflit d'intérêt avant on
parlait de quoi certains pays on parlera
de corruption
ça se fait aux États-Unis et ça permet
aux hommes politiques américains de pas
être dépendant financièrement de leur
parcours politique
il faut pas que le moral l'emporte sur
le légal très bien je vous pose une
question maintenant très simple pour ce
top là qui a marqué l'actualité de la
semaine en bien ou en mal cher Allen
vous allez commencer votre top et votre
flop de la semaine qu'est-ce que c'est
moi j'ai deux tops vous suggérer mon
premier top c'est et bien le fond
Marianne qui est dans le viseur
d'abord du parc national financier qui
lance une mission une enquête pour prise
illégale d'intérêt et également la
commission parlementaire qui est
demandée à l'unanimité par par le Sénat
je trouve ça pas normal qu'une non
qu'une tension c'est promouvoir les
valeurs de la laïcité lancer après
l'assassiné Samuel Paty et bien
bénéficier à des entreprises qui sont
qui ont quelques seulement quelques
salariés qui dénigrent des personnalités
politiques je trouve ça il faut de la
transparence et votre autre flop un peu
plus léger pour un roi un peu moderne et
écolo qui qui vient d'être couronné
Charles III voilà depuis les années 70
il nous parle d'écologie ils soutient en
Greta tel il mange pas de viande il a
dit une ferme bio
Christophe votre top et votre flop alors
d'abord le top ou d'abord le flop que
vous voulez dans le flop là c'est je
dois dire c'est vadimetv
qui a été autrefois vice-président de la
Russie qui a été un libéral qui a été
quelqu'un qui apportait plutôt un espoir
on pourrait dire d'ouverture à la Russie
et puis qui sait transformé en un
ultra-nationaliste extrême et c'est bien
dommage cette évolution est très
préjudiciable parce que il l'aurait pu
incarner une ouverture et il incarne la
fermeture et mon top alors là c'est un
peu de la provogue je m'en excuse c'est
l'auteur Bruno Le Maire parce que j'en
ai marre de voir tout le monde taper sur
le dernier roman de Bruno Le Maire alors
je n'ai comme tout le monde je n'ai lu
que le passage
érotique qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux d'abord c'est une erreur
technique évidemment ou même politique
de la part de son éditeur d'avoir sorti
ce livre là au milieu de la réforme des
retraites alors qu'il est ministre de
l'Économie enfin bref c'est une grave
erreur mais Bruno Le Maire c'est un bon
écrivain je me souviens qu'il avait
publié il y a quelques années un très
beau livre sur le chef d'orchestre
Carlos clyber qui était très émouvant
très intéressant c'est quelqu'un qui a
une plume c'est quelqu'un qui a du
talent d'écriture alors je ne je ne je
ne je ne le juge pas en tant que
ministre de l'économie mais je pense
qu'il faut le défendre en tant
qu'écrivain très rapidement s'il vous
plaît alors flop c'est l'agence de
notation Fitch parce que la suite de sa
dégradation de la note de la France ça
n'a eu absolument aucun effet sur les
marchés financiers qui sont restés
strictement indifférent à cette à cette
dégradation donc ça prouve qu'ils ont
pas une influence absolument
considérable et le top c'est les députés
français menés par Julien Bayou mais
avec un LR je crois et un socialiste qui
se sont élevés contre les conditions de
location par Airbnb je pense que c'est
un vrai sujet et qu'il y a un vrai
problème de logement dans ce pays et qui
va falloir qu'on encadre mieux pour que
les gens puissent continuer Alexandre
votre top of flop en 10 secondes vous
allez pouvoir faire ça
un peu expliqué pourquoi tout à l'heure
parce que plus il attaque le
rassemblement national plus il met ou
j'aurais la mélodie plus mais en exergue
la pauvreté de son propre bilan et le
deuxième flop c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel je sais pas très bien on
en fait une vache à créer démocratique
ce sont des gens non élus qui n'ont pas
de légitimité le deuxième risque et qui
ont rejeté le deuxième RIB et moi je
pense que c'est très important
aujourd'hui de revenir au peuple de
consulter le peuple parce qu'on voit
bien qu'il y a une fracture ce serait
bien qu'on revienne à cet outil qui est
dans la 5e République le référendum
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir participé merci à tous les cas
merci président de la recherche un grand
salut à vous derrière votre écran on me
dit dans l'oreillette que vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux à nous suivre
merci à vous vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même jour
même heure et même endroit bye bye
[Musique]